over the past two weeks I've been
spotlighting various black voices to
learn as much as I can during these
insane times my guest tonight is a very
talented comedian and actor who has
carved his own unique path through the
entertainment industry he's also one of
the most loving fathers I know
his new show nice one will be premiering
later this summer on kwibi please
welcome my really good friend Ron
Funches Ron good to see you hey Coco
how you doing how dare you call me Coco
just respect me you know we have so much
to talk about obviously the last two
weeks has been so many things it's been
traumatic and upsetting and at times
violent and there's I mean I think what
what good is coming out of it is that
there's been a lot of discussion and
we've been we've been trying to do that
here on the show one of the things that
I want to talk to you about is that when
when you saw what happened to George
Floyd I'm sure this brought up a lot of
feelings about your own son your son who
has you've worried about you've weren't
you say that you've told me in in the
past that you about your son and about
your son's autism and that this has been
a specific concern of yours for his
safety out in the world yeah absolutely
it's been a concern of mine for many
years it's one of my most motivating
things in my life just that because of
him being mixed-race me and half black
and half way and having autism and not
being you know he's just doesn't follow
directions as easily he doesn't respond
to directions as quickly as some people
would like and I was always concerned
that that if he was in an altercation
with a police officer that that could
mean the end of his life so there was
something that was deeply concerned to
the point where you know I didn't
like him out of my sight that much I
didn't and a lot of my motivation was
trying to insulate that with money being
like okay if we can surround him in a
good neighborhood if we can surround him
it would would a nanny that's there even
though he's 17 years old we have a
full-time nanny just to make sure that
someone is with him and it is not
because he's not independent he's very
independent is a lot to do with my fear
about what could happen with
misunderstandings with others especially
people like the police people with power
yeah and and you know I was talking
yesterday to the mayor of st. Paul
Minnesota and we were talking about this
this concept that maybe in some
situations you don't it shouldn't be
automatic that the police are called
that it might be some sort of health
workers that are called for some
situations so that response is a little
more nuanced and that's something you've
thought about with your son which is you
know you don't necessarily want the
police showing up if if you're having an
issue with your son knowing that that
really says a lot right there that if
you are in a bad situation if you're if
if things are feeling out of control
like you you don't want the police
because the fear is that they will
escalate the situation their job is
usually to just try to get the piece in
order as quick as possible and if that
means removing a situation if that means
they have to shoot someone it seems like
that is a quicker option to them then
trying to figure out what the problem is
trying to be empathetic to what the
problem is
it's something I deal with when my son
was younger when he was five six seven
years old and he would be overwhelmed by
different stimulus he would have these
big Tantrums and it would involve people
calling the police
to my house and I was lucky that it
never escalated but it did end up with
like you know no one ever came over and
say hey what can we do to help what was
the issue was going on instead they
would come over they would tell us to
shut it down
shut him up and then they would call
child services and then we'd have to
deal with that it was always like you're
a bad parent or you don't know what
you're doing as opposed to you need help
and I think that's something where
health services and people trained and
that can be much more help especially
didn't want anyone with any type of
mental diversity or disability you don't
want someone who's not familiar with
that coming into the situation I believe
that your son Malcolm is named after
Malcolm X is that right yes that is
correct it's interesting because when I
look at the actual footage of Malcolm X
he's the most one of the most
charismatic person the people I've ever
seen captured in documentary footage
he's got that same thing that Muhammad
Ali had where he can't just he's such a
powerful presence and can it rapture you
yeah exactly is it when did you when did
you I mean obviously if you named your
son Malcolm it must have been an
important figure to you is this your
whole life
I started probably 11 12 years old when
I was getting ready to leave Chicago one
of the best things that my school ever
did for me was take me to go see the
Autobiography of Malcolm X with starring
Denzel Washington and that kind of
started my infatuation with him and then
I read his autobiography and then I
started to read more speeches that he
had done and then it became clear to me
that like this was a guy who had become
marginalized by history as dislike just
black separatists that all his stuff was
about like you know separating black
people from white people and that was
the that was not the truth it was all
about black love and pride and a lot of
it was just about power in an oppression
in and unionizing and in healthcare he
talked about a lot of things about
unionizing and healthcare that are still
needed to this day that we don't deal
with in and I think it's it's so funny
that people go back and and they they
glorify rightfully so Martin Luther King
but they also whitewash his history he
was not
he was more militant than people think
and Malcolm X was less militant than
people think they both just talked about
they were like two sides of a coin they
were headed to the same direction and I
think um you know now they invoke Martin
Luther King's name to kind of pacify us
they kind of say you're supposed to just
march in speech and you know that's what
Martin do now if you don't do that
you're disrespecting Martin Luther King
it's just like I don't want to hear that
from when he was on the FBI's most
wanted list when he was murdered by our
government when those are things that
now they celebrate him when they did hit
the damnedest to discredit him to say
that he was a womanizer and to to kill
him and then now you know they'd wanna
tell another story right right one of
the things that I'm you know I don't
think I was unaware of this but but what
I'm hearing again and again from from
friends of mine is who are black is that
they they say that they experience
racism sometimes but it's almost at a
frequency that their white friends don't
pick up on it but black people pick up
on it and it's something that you're
quite familiar with you'll be in a
situation where something might happen
and you'll feel wait a minute that
didn't feel right to me but your white
friends who you think are pretty woke
don't don't hear it is that true yeah it
is true it seems to be just operation
how do I put it
did you think you have to prove it to
them but if they don't see it firsthand
if it's not someone calling you the
n-word if it's not someone throwing you
to the ground I think that's what made
the George Floyd situation so
unavoidable that you could look at it
directly and you see the smugness you
see the lack of empathy you see the fact
that he has his knee on the back of the
person's neck which is not needed for
any situation so you couldn't avoid it
but a lot of other things you can
a lot of the things that people would
come to me like whoa maybe you misheard
or maybe you just picked up the wrong
tone or maybe you had a bad day and I've
been lucky that like like my best friend
my friend Gabe who features for me he
he's been more open to it because
probably because he had a black stepdad
for a while he had a lot of black
members and his family and I remember
recently we were traveling and we just
stopped in his airport for coffee and
then the guy was was giving out coffee
to people and the my friend was before
me and he talked to my friend he's like
hey good morning how's everything going
how's the how's your day where you
headed to and he gets to me and he
doesn't say a word to me he just has
order he gives me my coffee and he shuts
completely down and then the next person
that comes by is a white lady and he's
back to the same and so then I was like
okay I get it and then I was fortunate
at that time that my friend was there to
look over and go oh that guy so he's a
racist and sometimes that's what you
need it's not necessarily that that
ruined my day or I cared that much about
that coffee I have learned to this
situation of like I'm just passing
through if that's how he's living he's
having a horrible day and he's racist
well then that's where he belongs just
serving coffee out in the middle of
nowhere I'm passing through but what
sometimes that we need is just
validation just knowing that hey even if
you didn't see it even if you don't want
to believe it it happens and you gotta
take people's word for it I think that's
the thing that I've been seeing the most
is that like the african-american
community is the only group that has to
prove that they didn't deserve to die
you know they have to explain why Oh
what did he do why you get something oh
well he enjoyed for it had a record he
did this 2007 he did this 2009 it's like
there's no other race there's no other
group that you'd have to explain why you
don't deserve to be murdered yeah yeah
you and I went on a tour a year ago a
little over a year ago and we spent a
lot of time together and so was there
anything that happened
while we were on that tour together that
that made you feel at all strange or
feel marginalized while we were on the
road together or on different tours
undone some different tours definitely I
wouldn't say there was any event that
happened on our tour I would say the
only thing that I was aware of is that I
had his mindset that if I strayed too
far from the group that some people
might be like oh what are you doing
where are you like where you are you
trying to get into this like are you are
you trying to rob them or are you trying
like you don't belong here
basically wait where did this where did
you feel this it it's a feeling that I
carried that I'm that I should not get
too far from the group that I should had
to show them that I was with you because
if I felt that if I was alone they go oh
why are you in this fancy hotel why are
you here what are you doing here and
that happens to me more on like because
I love to travel I love the vacation and
that's happened to me several times on
vacation or several times in nice stores
where I would I used to do this thing
that if they treat me poorly I'd buy
more stuff so that I proved to them you
were wrong and now I was like no I'm
just not gonna make sure you just don't
get that Commission you know right so
what you're saying is in order to prove
this that you were there with good
intent you would like buy a canoe even
if you didn't want to that's the
strangest response to feeling
marginalized you see a lot of time it's
called peacocking it's something that
has happens in the black community where
you see a lot of like fancy cars fancy
clothes because it's this showcase of
like hey you shouldn't treat me poorly
instead of it being like I'm a human so
you shouldn't treat me poorly it you you
know that's one of the biggest lessons I
learned as a young black man is that I
thought for some strange dumb reason I
thought like oh if I get a little bit of
money then they'll stop treating me like
this and then I learned that that was so
you'll be honor I mean you've done very
well you'll be on a big
you'll be staying in a nice place and
you'll sometimes sense that people are
wondering how is he here what's he doing
here is he a guest of this hotel I've
had it happen I've had a bellhop try to
stop me from entering my own hotel room
because I went outside for a jog and I
come back in my shorts and I'm sweaty
and he's just like hey what are you
doing here what are you doing here and
then I I have headphones on so I'm not
even paying attention so I just go
walking by and he starts following me
and yelling at me like who are you what
are you doing here so I just turn around
and I show him my keycard and then I
flip him off that was the end of that
right right I'm glad you had the correct
response you were able to do that
there's this belief some people have
that racism is there's a it's a
generational aspect to racism that that
it's it's worse with older generations
but as we move on and people get younger
and and newer generations come along
it's getting better that is not always
been your experience right no not always
I mean I do believe that there is always
progress and I think the more that we
become culturally mixed the more that
these kids are growing up off of hip-hop
and and seeing black people in positions
of power and representation the better
it gets but no I know plenty you you
turn on a game of Call of Duty turn on
any video game and it's not your grandpa
calling me the n-word
you know it's a 12 year old kid it's a
13 year old kid and you see it at these
these Trump rallies they're not eighty
year old people right here 20 year old
white men who have found a way to make
themselves feel disenfranchised make
themselves feel like the victim and use
that that national that white pride and
that racism to fuel themselves so it to
me that's one of the biggest disservice
we do as a community is going oh well we
just need to wait 10 20 years for our
grandparents to die that's like well
we've been waiting a hundred years for
that it's so those grandparents teach
the kids who teach the grandkids and and
it
you got to look within yourself it's not
just about your parents you have a very
unique comedic voice and style and if
something I always really admired about
you and yet at the same time I'm
imagining it's been a struggle for you
to not get typecast because of the color
of your skin yeah absolutely absolutely
I knew that from first when I went to
Montreal was a new face gentleman
Brendan Johnson who is a great
african-american comedian and actor came
up to me and he was like oh I saw your
set he's like I mean he's like you're
weird
and you're black your rows going to be
different and longer and strange but
keep being you don't ever change for
these people and I've always kept that
and it's been a source of anger and
frustration for me that my comedy is
built off of love it's built off of
empathise but out of optimism it's built
off of making the best of a bad
situation and a lot of times the roles
that that are offered to me or that of a
gang member or that of a guy fresh out
of jail are that of a guy where I have
to change the way I speak to speak more
urban to to fit into a role that they
want me to fit into and I just don't
feel that that's fair especially in this
time period they do you know it
we still representation I think is one
of the biggest things laws are going to
be very important just not police
brutality obviously is step is a great
step but representation and being
willing to show different facets of the
black community is something that we
still struggle with every day every
pilot season I get just more and more
sitcoms where either it's a struggle
role of a black guy lifting himself out
of poverty or it's Oh clearly a white
role that they're trying to shoehorn
some diversity into and there's just
multiple black stories and multiple
types of way that people can be viewed
in the community and that's something I
try to write towards and try to create
because I don't like the roles that I'm
off
basically mm-hmm the I know that there
was you've you've been on my show many
times always been hilarious you did
stand-up on my show once and I know
there was a joke you wanted to do or
that you were planning to do and the
joke involved you using the n-word and I
don't think I was aware of this at the
time but our one of our producers said
well you can't say that word on Turner
Broadcasting so we were in the position
of being white and telling you you can't
use the n-word which was just sort of a
weird situation was that something that
bothered you when that happened of
course it bothered me a little bit but
it wasn't something that I didn't expect
and you know I was like let me attempt
to do this joke because I love it and
again I think it shows my style of
someone who looks at for the positive in
every negative situation but I didn't
expect you guys to let me say the n-word
on TV so I wasn't mad about it but I you
know when you look at it you go like
this is just a weirder form of
oppression where you where there's a
guilt about this word that you know that
we've taken as a black community to the
source of empowerment for us and then
there go like okay well now that you
guys don't hate it as much you can't say
it can I can I hear the joke can we hear
the joke I don't remember it 100% cuz it
was years ago but I remember the event
it was just about the time I was going
to go get my son Papa Murphy's taking
baked pizza what was walking across my
apartment across this two-lane big
street that we had and as I was growing
across the street I hear this guy yeh
use the crosswalk in word and it pissed
me off because I was like oh man like
just so much racism in the world
everybody's full of hatred I'm just
trying to get my son a pizza but then I
thought oh yeah he's in a car maybe I
just didn't hear the rest of the
conversation he and what he was trying
to say was use the crosswalk I'm
worried
about safety that's a really good joke
you're always able to see the silver
lining I guess huh
[Laughter]
you know you've you we've hung out a lot
we spent a lot of time together we've
been in vans we've been on planes we've
been backstage I'm I'm trying to figure
out as best I can how I can you know how
I can learn and how I can grow and
evolve and so if you have advice for me
I'll take it sure I was thinking about
this last night because um you I think a
lot of people are at your position a lot
of way people are in your position where
they're there this is new to them I
appreciate you trying to look at but I
think a lot of it is like look don't be
so egotistical it's not about you it's
not it's about us it's about the things
that we go into and the fact that you
can be listen and open to that is great
but I thought I did a little bit more
thinking and I thought the best thing I
could tell you is just be an active ally
be if you see you're in a privileged
position that sometimes white people
will reveal their racism to you because
you're white and they don't think that
you might have an issue with it or you
they might feel more comfortable with
revealing their true selves to you as
opposed to me you know and I think if
you are in that position and you see
that to never let that go to never
always check people if they are in that
position and you see them acting out
allowing or treating someone poorly to
never let them know that that is okay
that that is to think that is the best
thing that you can do okay okay I have
had the experience over the years of
African Americans black people whenever
I see them and they're familiar with my
show they always say the same thing
you're crazy
white and lily-white as you are you are
loved in the black community I think
it's because you are so awkwardly tall
and look like an outcast yourself I
always say the same thing you may start
laughing and they say you're crazy
you're crazy
yes but always and actually it's a nice
way to start the conversation you know
which which which which works out well I
I really appreciate you coming on the
show and having this conversation with
me and I want to apologize again or on
tour singing songs towards you my guitar
when I think I knew it drove you crazy
[Laughter]
literally loved its me at my absolute
widest which is so white and I would see
you and I'd be like I'm gonna do it
again and you you are you considered it
a unique form of torture our
relationship is that I can say I can
tell you that you didn't just tell me
that you then went out in front of I
don't know 3,000 people in a giant venue
and you told them the most horrible
thing just happened to me you made fun
of me brutally in front of all these
people and I loved it it was absolutely
hilarious you know I figured if it
happened to me that much it must happen
to your staff all the time
so I needed to stand up for them you did
the right thing you did the right thing
well thank you so much for doing this I
love you I can't wait till we get to
hang out in person and and thank you so
much for doing this today you're a good
man thank you I love you too I
appreciate you doing this this is a
great thing that you do
and I think I like that you're looking
into yourself but you've always you've
done a great job you've hired diversity
like a lot of diversity of the fact that
you had Deon Cole on your show when I
was a young man meant a lot to me as a
young black comedian because it was one
of the few guys where I was like oh this
is not he's not doing a stereotype he's
not doing a stick he's the weird black
dude doing himself and you gave him a
platform to show that and and and then
in turn that empowered me yeah he's such
a funny guy and and you're such a funny
guy and well I'll see you soon I promise
you'll never hear me sing again please
all I do is if if I can grow that much I
can grow more all right thank you very
much Ron and I'll talk to you soon